[Music]
there you know Artie I was thinking
about putting out a comedy written
comedy you feelin singer a shake dancer
ha it's real hard to break him I'll do
whatever it takes Unni I come up with a
new character dolomite it's my name and
[ __ ] up [ __ ] it's my game
[Music]
it's all pretend I just created a
character future pull own it oh yeah
that's right but if it takes I'm ready
to do it
I got to be totally outrageous it's
filthy you've got a product here that
you can't sell or promote all my life
give them and tell them you know Rudy
sometimes our dreams just don't come
true I'm an slam I go in my face
I just found another door I want the
world of know I exist this ain't funny
and it ain't no brothers in it even if I
get up in that light with my own movie
and be everywhere all at once
let's bring dolomite to the screen the
actors we hire a big dough you than them
doughy
come on I'm offering you a role in my
new motion picture do you think you
could just walk up here and hire me know
what if we let you direct in
storytelling it's always best to write
what you know you need to talk about my
personal life I deal with tonight night
club owners and mobsters lots of pimps
and kung foo do you know karate
no but I'm a fast learner I can learn to
chop me a month action
[Music]
yeah it's a ninja way tonight he could
be a sex machine what planet is this get
on this thing flops you're gonna be
working for free for the rest of your
life I'm so grateful for what you did
for me cuz I never seen nobody that
looks like me now up there on that big
screen
god damn dolomite great karna heaven
cut was it good a shape
[Music]
[Music]